Lindsey is with us in New Hampshire hi
Lindsey how are you good how are you
Dave better than I deserve what's up in
your world so I am currently taking
Financial Peace University through our
local church and we're in baby step
number two paying off all of our debt
and I just was closing my credit card
accounts today and I found it
interesting that when I went to close my
Amazon card which is a chase credit card
the woman on the phone actually said
that Chase has developed cue cards for
people calling up data following the
Dave Ramsey planned script forum on how
to beat the Dave Ramsey no and she still
tried to convince me to keep a credit
card because for some reason you know
renting a car or having hotel you know
you can't use your debit card for that
and I'm like do you think I'm going to
fall for this if I'm following the Dave
Ramsey plan what did she say she just
kept going just keep going going and
going it's like a dog chasing its tail
yes but I was like I have to call the
Dave Ramsey show entitlements because I
don't know if anybody has told them yeah
we hear from time to time they've got
some scripts built in with different
ones but I hadn't heard it on the chase
card with Amazon now that's I mean
Citicorp and Chase and Wells Fargo these
big banks they they spend an amazing
amount of money just trying to save once
they spend the money to get you to get a
credit card then they spent a lot of
money trying to save the the sale they
don't lose the sale because they made a
sale to you and then I want to keep
getting your money and so Wow so they
actually have that built in scripts for
Dave Ramsey now they have built in
scripts for Dave Ramsey not only now
you're making a huge impact I mean I'm
so honored it's a mutual hate Society
the case stand me and I for sure
them because they've been screwing the
consumer for so many decades I have no
use form at all that's fabulous
yeah thanks for sharing that that that
makes my day little ol kid down here in
Nashville Tennessee and they're all
worried about me look at that who would
have thought those big important New
York people yeah well the problem is
it's not me the problem is there's about
15 million of you hearing this
conversation right the second that's the
problem with these idiots at chase F Oh
bless their hearts
that's southern for them I'll kill you